la plupart des organismes publics au
québec peine à atteindre leurs objectifs
en matière d'employés issus des
minorités visibles et ethniques
clairement les résultats ne sont pas au
rendez vous dans son rapport la
commission des droits de la personne et
de la jeunesse observe que la proportion
de minorités visibles est passé de 2,7
pour cent en 2009 à 6,3 pour cent 2019
alors que la cible est de 10,3 pour cent
une des explications est que le
programme d'accès à l'égalité pour
contrer la discrimination en emploi est
encore mal compris et il ya encore des
idées des préjugés à savoir que telle
personne a eu un poste
ce n'est pas sur la base de ses
compétences mais pour combler les
besoins du programme
parmi les sociétés publiques où il reste
des efforts à faire il y as entre la
société des alcools du québec sur 7500
employés 122 sont issus de minorités
visibles
il en manque 569 pour atteindre la cible
chez hydro-québec sur plus de 19000
employés seulement 706 sont issus de
minorités visibles
on a mis en place plusieurs programmes
ont fait beaucoup de sensibilisation
auprès de nos gestionnaires nos équipes
de recrutement également pour s'assurer
que acv ou à candidatures
identique une personne issue d'une
minorité visible ou annick encore sa
chance mais il faut faire davantage
comme le souligne le premier ministre
françois legault
mais moi je reconnais qu'un problème est
un problème autun dans les ministères
que dans les sociétés d'état il ya une
sous représentation entre autres des
minorités visé il y a de bons élèves
notamment les sociétés de transport qui
possède les représentations les plus
élevés pour la commission il faudra
aussi se pencher sur les postes de
gestionnaires et de cadres ou le
phénomène du plafond de verre est encore
présent et si mélissa françois radio
canada montréal